[Music]
who brought down Matt Lauer now saying
that she lived in constant fear there is
new fallout tonight as the Today Show
tackles their homegrown scandal head-on
there's a hunt underway to figure out
who she is appearing on The Today Show
this morning a lawyer for the anonymous
accuser whose complaint led to Lauer's
termination directly accused the network
of not doing enough to protect her
identity NBC has a duty to maintain
confidentiality and they have not done a
good job of doing that they know exactly
what they've done and they need to stop
her lawyer would not reveal specifics of
how NBC may have compromised his clients
identity however a spokesperson for NBC
News tells ET quote the network has
protected the employees anonymity all
along and will continue to do so she
does live in constant fear that people
are going to track her down and I think
that's gonna have a chilling effect on
other women who might want to come
forward Lauer's latest accuser is chosen
to reveal herself
Addie's a known a former production
assistant on today tells ET the decision
was made partially out of fear for being
outed quote the media was coming for me
so instead of allowing someone else to
write my narrative I decided to stop
protecting him blaming myself and
allowing fear to hold me hostage
zyne own accuses Lauer of abuse of power
in 2000 when at 24 years old she says
they engaged in a one month long affair
neither NBC or Lauer have commented on
the allegations in 2009 Lauer did not
join his colleagues and taping messages
of support when the known was inducted
into Temple University's media Hall of
Fame Addie is a really delightful young
woman I can think of no one more
deserving to the inducted into the Hall
of Fame
you